how many of you workout in your bedroom
let's do it towards a body workout okay
let's work on your legs your core
muscles and also your upper body so
these exercises can be done with minimal
space it's only eight minutes long so do
it first thing in the morning and kick
start your day so each workout will be
for 45 seconds long with 15 seconds of
rest in between so use the side of your
bed or even your table okay let's do the
first workout which is mountain climber
keep your arms close together with your
elbows points back okay we want to bring
your heart rate up let's go so climb
drive your knees close your chest and
bring your knees close to the bed
very good so tiptoe and just climb
keeping your back flat very good again
these exercises you won't need a lot of
space at all keep climbing drive it in
run okay run good very very good so
remember to pace your breathing breathe
in and breathe out this is a great
workout to boost your metabolism
first thing in the morning keep going
keep elbows relaxed with your shoulders
relaxed nice not too more and rest it
out next workout split lunch let's work
on your legs so step your right leg
forward bring your left leg back okay
step it wider and we want to get into a
lunge position all right ready
last two seconds and go so this workout
will really target on one leg at a time
now we're working on your right leg go
low as slow as you can good squeeze and
push up with your heels squeeze your
glute muscles very good there you go it
will also work on your balance okay so
it's all about engaging your core
muscles look straight ahead and find the
focal point find that balance
very very good keep going go low down
slow up bus down slow push it up push
using your heels and on the second run
we want to work on the left leg keep
going down and up good
fifteen seconds rest shake it out now
let's lick down right leg up okay find
your balance step wider if you need to
and bring your left knee down
very good ready and let's go it down and
just relax your right leg it's all about
working on one leg at a time and
sometimes some of us might suffer from
muscle imbalance so this single leg
lunch it's a really good workout to
target on single leg at a time
good keep breathing keep your hands
forward and just relax your upper body
open up your chest and stay low good
keep going you should feel that your
heart rate is going up right now breathe
in and breathe out so breathe in and
breathe out as you push up again push
using your Hulme good very good squeeze
your left cheek down control squeeze and
just press it up now bingo wings okay so
try that beeps okay sit down keep it up
as close point them back all the way
through bring your body forward okay you
have to keep your body close to your bed
or even your table low it down push it
up slow it down and push it up remember
to keep your elbows close to your body
okay do not spread them this is wrong so
they should always be pointed back and
your body should be close to the bed
chair or table again this is wrong okay
keep it closed keep it tight
using your triceps push yourself up
lower yourself down if this is too
difficult
bend your knees to begin with very good
so bend your knees
and this will make the workout easier
good as you progress step wide and step
further down and push up with your
triceps last one more and rest it out
right again on your upper body elevated
push-ups for those of you who can't do
push-ups you want to start somewhere
this is a really good starting point
okay so using the side of your bed let's
go white arms down and up okay good down
and push up good so bring your chest
close to the bed down and push it up
good and always remember keeping your
back flat your entire body should be in
a straight line very good blow it down
push up down and up keep your elbows
slightly bent very very good okay as you
progress then you can do a full push-up
on the floor very good keep going push
up down loose and up last few more give
me two more okay one last one more down
and up oh now it works on your lower
body and your upper body let's do some
core work on knee tucks again just relax
upper body
keep them close support your upper body
and we want to extend your legs
crunch it in extend and crunch okay so
gentle easy knee tucks alright bring
your knees close to your chest very good
tuck it in you should really feel your
upper and your lower abs working at the
same time point your toes
tuck and tuck so lower your body down in
and out good keep going in and out and
keep breathing
the more you pace your breathing the
better you will perform at your workout
good keep going
let's go give me a few more and rest it
out still working on your call bicycle
crunches okay right so again just sit
right at the corner of the bed right
hands up all right point your toes and
we want to twist and work on your
obliques ready shake it out a little bit
let's go slight twist and work on your
obliques keep your toes pointed twist
and reach your knee to your elbow good
keep reaching keep pointing very good
the more you twist the more you will be
working on your oblique muscles and
remember keep your chest open open up
your chest oh my god I can really feel
the burn right now haha 20 seconds left
do not stop right now guys it's only a
45 seconds workout for each of them keep
going point point a toast give me a nice
deep twist that's two more last one more
on each side and all right we're not
done yet
bye the best parts just lie down on your
bed ah let's work on reverse crunches
and let's really work on your lower abs
okay you can either hold on to your bed
or just keep your hands by your side
okay bring it up down if you need to
venya needs to begin with bring it down
and up
very good so it's all about engaging the
lower abs lifting your tailbone slightly
off off the floor good up straighten
your legs if you want to up and down up
keep going
this is your final workout of caste much
as I can point your toes
keep your legs straight I know your core
is burning because my car is absolutely
burning point it lifts your tailbone off
slightly up crunch and press it out just
lie down on your bed stretch it out and
breathe in oh my gosh so that was a
really shot eight minute workout which
you can do from the comfort of your own
room all right no excuses a short
workout is better than no workout and
you can get your workout done anywhere
no matter how small the space is get
this workout done like this video share
this video tag your friends get them to
do this workout together with you and
don't forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more workout
challenges and also healthy recipes
right hop into the shower and start your
day all the best